good morning Adam good morning Dan how
are you doing I'm doing okay you know we
downsized here in the man cave we're
down to a couple I got some Dan that's
on location they're at their homes but
everything else is good very responsible
of you we are
I think redefining how the world will
work moving forward I think this will
change a lot of things will be
interesting to see the full out of
everything what do you expect to find
out from Alan sills the NFL chief
medical officer on the impact of the
corona virus well this is a situation
really where I think he gets put front
and center and Alan sills is a brain
surgeon by day and is in charge of all
these issues for the NFL so he is the
one that is basically debriefing the
teams to briefing the league office to
briefing Roger Goodell on the daily
matters that face the NFL and I think
right now they're just trying to act
like everybody else responsibly and do
the right thing and look the draft is
scheduled to go on April 23rd 25th I
don't see how it's going to happen with
teams conducting it from their
headquarters and talking to a number of
executives for an office personnel or
coaches over the weekend they all think
that if the draft happens on those dates
and I don't think there's been too many
discussions about moving it so far Dan
but we're a month out but if it happens
those dates that this would be the first
draft done with remote teleconference
where GM's and front office members in
their home I'm communicating the way
that so many of us are these days which
would throw a new wrinkle unless the NFL
decides to move in and Alan sills of
course I would think would be at the
front center of that he's at the front
and center of what will be I think the
cancellation of all offseason activities
can't imagine how these teams are going
to go through anything like that the
five teams of new head coaches were
supposed to be able to get underway
Monday April 6 that's not going to
happen can't imagine it can happen
anytime soon and so they've got to
figure this all out just like everybody
else you got to figure it all out you
got your people out in the field you
know Phil's got his people at home I'm
working from home ESPN has people at
home and so that's just the way the
world is gonna have to operate for a
while now I don't want to put words in
your mouth but it's it sounded like you
were certainly going more than hinting
that the draft is going to be postponed
no no no I'm not doing that okay I'm
saying that the way the draft is done I
don't think is going to hold up now
again I want to be very clear I don't
think the NFL is discussed moving it off
those dates at this point okay I think
the NFL is determined to have the draft
at that point April 23rd to the 25th my
just guessing is if it's done that way
it's going to be done with
teleconferencing from home and there's
no assurances that that happens that's
my own thing I don't know Dan look at
the window look at the world oh I know
you I don't think these Scouts can do
their due diligence the teams can't you
can't be in person with somebody for
workouts there's no pro days that's why
I mean I I would be surprised if the
draft happens just because we're not
allowing people to do their jobs and
like when how many times have we seen a
team on the clock executing a trade they
got the GM on the phone with the other
GM they got the assistant on the phone
with the league office ready to turn in
it's all these people working together
simultaneously now again we haven't been
in a situation to understand how it
works but can you do that with everybody
on a FaceTime call can you do it through
zoom I I don't know I I really have no
idea but if that is the case then maybe
there needs to be more time I'm a clock
for teams and allowance for that or
maybe they're gonna have to move it back
and wait till everybody can be back in
the office whether that's a month from
now two months from now four months from
now we don't know we're in a whole new
world here but you also have to who puts
out a video because you can't go and
visit him you can't have a pro day and
you know you have teams go out there and
see him in person did he help his stock
at all if you I don't know if you've
talked to anybody about it but I'm
assuming you have did he help himself
out with that video look he's gonna be
able to control the narrative and show
teams videos of how well he's healing
and it looks encouraging but the bottom
line remains I don't think it changes
anything team's doctors cannot get their
hands on him they cannot put him through
a physical examination we have no idea
about the blood flow in that area we
have no idea
exactly how that hit the ceiling it's
one thing to just put out a video where
it looks like you're moving well what's
really going on in there I have no idea
and the teams don't either you look at
it on the surface we say hey you're
excited for the young man and it looks
like he's certainly progressing but some
team is going to be making a major
investment into a-- and that investment
is going to be in the form of dollars
and maybe draft picks by moving up and
he was always going to be something of a
medical gamble not his talent he's a
number one overall pick talent we're not
questioning that we're just saying that
there are questions about the hip the
ankles the durability that was the
question on him coming out so if that
was a question then without anybody
putting him through an examination other
than the exam and Indianapolis at the
combine in late February aren't those
questions still going to be there
whenever the draft is hell yes we're
talking to Adam Schefter the mothership
if I told you a month ago that these
moves would happen what's the one that
you would say I didn't see that one
coming of all the moves that have
happened over the last ten or so days
day yeah I guess teddy bridgewater to
Carolina we didn't really talk about
that one no you know people thought
Teddy would wind up in Tampa and some
guy named Tom Brady took that slot and
it bounced teddy bridgewater to Carolina
which also signed he except I'll stand
out PJ Walker which means that Carl
Allen gets traded for a fifth round pick
when the Panthers I don't think we're
gonna be able to get back anything for
Cam Newton so think about that for a
second Kyle you can't even get anything
back for Cam Newton and you can't get
anything back for Cameroon I don't think
if they came good for them because of
the world we live in again medical
issues former NFL MVP teams want to
examine him and you're not going to
trade for a guy do 19 1 million with
medical questions when you can't put the
guy through a physical so that becomes
problematic so in this day and age in
this offseason
Kyle Allen through drastic compensation
is be more valuable than Cam Newton as
crazy as that is or Kyle yeah right
exactly yeah I get it right how many
think how many teams you think we're
truly interested in braiding to make an
offer
well I could tell you this Dan I think
there were various teams at various
points going through various exercises
about whether or not they would make a
run at Bray so what you say a team like
the Bears had conversations about
whether they should go after Tom Brady
and wait does that count as a team
that's interested or not no I'm just
asking somebody who was ready to make an
offer there okay I would count in my
mind
well teams that ultimately did write
yeah ultimately three teams probably the
Patriots Buccaneers well before I was
even Queen the Patriots because I don't
think I don't there enough fur
everywhere Spade there
I mean really this was this was a case
where Tom was kind of dictating it to
them and and and and I don't think I
think they were sitting back waiting for
him and it was mixed up with the salary
cap or the CBA being approved that
Saturday night or Sunday morning and so
you had to see what rules you were
operating under but then once they knew
it never seemed to take off with New
England because Tom had to talk with
Robert Kraft to let him know he's moving
on so III don't think they ever sat down
the two sides and said this is what
we're thinking of offering you really to
my I don't think they have I don't think
they did and it was either and it was it
wasn't one of those situations where
that would have been hard to figure out
if Tom wanted to be I think I think both
sides as much as they love and respect
each other I think that I think that's a
people are losing sight of a little bit
I know that people want to focus on the
negative aspect of the oh boy they're
there
and Tom didn't feel appreciated or each
guy wanted to do things don't you know
again I think these guys were together I
mean Tom and Bill in the craft twenty
years what six Super Bowls right and so
as it was brought up to me by somebody
involved in the process like there are
people who work for companies for 20
years is everything perfect no but it's
a great runner there are couples that
are married for 20 years is everything
personally not and some couples after 20
years they just say you know what
enjoyed it great time
some cherished memories just want to go
do something different I think both
sides did the right thing here I don't
disagree that yeah I think that that
because I I was at ESPN for 18 years and
there you go okay so so did well when
you left there initially you're probably
a little a little missed that it didn't
go exactly you would have wanted right
no I wanted to leave yeah okay I didn't
like how it played out the after I left
but I I just wanted to have fun I wasn't
having fun
and it's a lot of it's of my fault not
necessarily ESPN it had changed I wanted
I wanted to move on so I understand this
completely you were Tom Brady thank you
for Tom Brady came along yeah absolutely
that did and and and let's just call
like it you just didn't want to work
with me I just Eisen gave me a bad
scouting report on you and I run down
let's just go quickly here if you could
place these quarterbacks not where you
think they'll end up but place them
where would you place Jameis Winston let
me say this before you before we play
this game right yeah the hard part is is
the chairs are all filled in so now it
may be a team that says let's go take a
flyer on this guy that doesn't even make
a lot of sense like I'll give you some
teams that are out there that I think it
would be smarter than to sauna correct
Pittsburgh makes some sense to me
Jacksonville has got an opening behind
mermen shoe that makes some sense to me
uh if I were a quarterback I would say
you know what I want to go
to a place where I'm going to learn like
I want to go to San Francisco and work
under Kyle Shanahan I want to go to
Kansas City and work under Andy Reid and
so what's the difference if Jameis
Winston gets paid I'm making this up 8
million in Jacksonville worth 4 million
in Kansas City or 3 million if that's
going to improve his long-term status
and and elevated game and he's going to
learn so it's not even a question at
this point in time of where you think it
would make sense so much is what would
be the right fit for that guy whether
it's Jameis or Cam or Andy Dalton or any
other quarterback you can ask me what's
going to be the best fit for them long
term and it may be a team that we
haven't even talked about quarterback
well I'd see Jameis Pittsburgh to me
makes the most sense because he would be
better than their backup quarterbacks
they have now he gets to be around
Tomlin
Roethlisberger great organization and
then you get that opportunity maybe in
two years when Ben decides that he's not
gonna play anymore now you can do what
Ryan Tannehill did you wait your turn
and then you get your opportunity to
sort of have to reinvent yourself I
don't know what Andy Dalton does or Cam
Newton does yeah I don't know if you
know the Tyrod Taylor is gonna be the
band-aid in with the Chargers then
you're not going to bring in somebody
else there and you're gonna draft a
quarterback and I get it I understand
what you're saying and then I Cam Newton
to Jacksonville to me would make sense
from the standpoint of Gardner's your
guy and you know cam is still there and
can help but you know the I don't know
what their egos are like hey I'm gonna
go hey I'll be a backup no worries
Jameis would probably be a backup and so
would Dalton how about Green Bay in the
mix right like that would be another
team that you wouldn't necessarily think
of but let me go back up Aaron Rodgers
37 let me go learn there and see how
that works yeah and that's the kind of
thing I'm talking about here like how
about if you're Cam Newton is it worth
taking a flier say you know let me let
me go to Dallas in the event that they
can't figure out this contract situation
and I'll take over for deck Prescott
well I thought Jameis Winston with
Dallas because that gives you a little
bit of insurance if it doesn't work out
dak and now you have Jameis at age 26 I
thought that that made sense but people
said I was crazy am I crazy
well no it didn't you're never crazy no
yes I got that's a hell no I don't think
so
again these quarterback it was always
going to be a question of there were
more this was the first time ever there
were more quarterbacks available than
starting jobs ever ever and so there
were going to be people like Jameis and
Cam and any other quarterback we want to
put into that situation that we're going
to be in this spot they are today where
it's hard to find a landing spot you
birth the Chargers yet Tyra Taylor that
that's the guy
and they drafted Easton stick last year
who they happen to like and I expected
to draft a quarterback somewhere hi
whether it's round 1 2 3 whatever it may
be and so if you draft a guy and you
like east and sticking have Tyrod Taylor
with your blue there's your quarterback
room right there yeah yeah I'll leave
you with this the team that had the
worst off season so far as who the worst
off season who stands up to you McLovin
give adam the candidates so we put up a
poll the Texans the Cowboys the Rams the
Jaguars and Patriots I'd say you know
listen I never like to put anybody in a
category like that but if you're the
Rams you got to be discouraging
discouraged about losing the guy and
girly and having to make some of those
moves it's been a tough season for them
that that would be a candidate and and
you know and and that would stand out to
me yeah I could have done it where I
would rank in order of these teams who
had the best offseason and then
eventually get to the Rams as the worst
of those teams yep it's all semantics
there thank you for spending some time I
know you're busy and stay safe and thank
you again hey Dan I appreciate you I
hope you and the Dennett stay safe and
once again sorry we didn't get a chance
to work together at ESPN and you went
brady on us yeah
I went rogue on you Thank You Adam
that's Adam Schefter ESPN NFL insider